chantal mer le bon jour un jour vous
êtes la responsable de la bibliothèque
universitaire de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à guyancourt
depuis le lundi 4 juin vous accueillez
les lycéens dans leurs révisions pour le
bac le dispositif s'appelle révisé à la
baisse
b uf bien sûr pour bibliothèques
universitaires on se dit des lycéens
dans une baie eu ce n'est pas forcément
commun pourquoi les accueillir nous les
accueillons parce que ce sont des
potentiels étudiants à la fin de leurs
études secondaires et que la
bibliothèque a pour mission d'accueillir
tous publics dans ces espaces pour
se documenter s'informer et participer à
la réussite de ses études on ne sait pas
forcément les lycéens peuvent venir ici
toute l'année
oui la bibliothèque n'est pas sous
contrôle d'accès donc tous lycéens tout
étudiant et tous habitants de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines peut venir
bien sûr le public principal ce sont les
étudiants qui sont eux sont obligatoires
mois inscrits à la bibliothèque les
autres publics doivent s'inscrire à la
bibliothèque s'ils veulent profiter de
tous les services de la bibliothèque en
lice en sont actuellement en train de
réviser derrière nous ils sont nombreux
depuis le début du mois de juin vous
fait cette opération depuis lundi quatre
jours est-ce qu'ils sont nombreux à
venir y sus oui cette opération remporte
un franc succès puisque depuis lundi
donc ça fait à peu près dix jours nous
avons enregistré est inscrit et
accueilli plus de mille cent soixante
treize lycéens de tous les siens de tous
les lycées des environs
vendée c'est pas la première année ont
poussé pas la première année la
bibliothèque est ouverte depuis 2004 et
ça fait à peu près cinq ans qu'on a mis
en place ce dispositif puisque les
lycéens viennent de façon naturelle
révisé puisqu'ils cherchent des endroits
pour travailler mais c'est surtout on a
aussi nos propres étudiants qui sont
quelquefois un peu embêté gêné par les
lycéens
il faut arriver à faire cohabiter tous
ces publics différents avec des
objectifs différents
j'allais vous relancez là dessus pas de
gros problèmes de cohabitation il ya
quand même quelques soucis c'est ce que
ce que vous dites ça les étudiants se
sentent vraiment chez eux et quelquefois
quand les lycéens arrivent et qui font
un peu joué parce qu'il vient de réviser
en groupe
il faut trouver des moyens pour arriver
à faire cohabiter ces publics et c'est
pour ça qu'on a mis en place ce
dispositif pour accueillir les lycéens
les acculturés à ces espaces est aussi
garder des espaces à peu réservé pour
les étudiants vous en parlait il ya des
avantages bien sûr à venir révisé ici
pour le bac c'est d'abord un cadre on
imagine trouver de la tranquillité un
espace de travail idéales alors c'est
aussi pour changer d'endroit sortir de
son laisser grandir un peu
s'émanciper et commencer à découvrir un
peu la vie d'adulte et d'étudiants
l'intérêt c'est qu'ici la bibliothèque
on a de grands espaces ont appris que
1100 places assises et les lycéens se
sentent très dur pour venir c'est pour
ça qu'on met en place ce dispositif
c'est qu'on l'aimait plus tôt au
rez-de-chaussée pour garder les espaces
des étages plus tranquille pour les
étudiants c'est ça on est dans
l'auditorium c'est là qu'ils peuvent
réviser
on n'est pas dans l'éditorial on est au
niveau durée que j'aurai de chaussée et
l'auditorium c'est aussi un espace qu on
a aménagé pour que les lycéens puissent
travailler un peu plus tranquillement
puisque vous voyez bien que cet espace
résonne beaucoup et qu'on a aussi des
soucis d'acoustique et d'aménagement
d'un espace
on nous livre comme ça donc à nous
d'arriver à trouver des
des arrangements pour que tout le monde
puisse travailler le mieux possible et
se concentrer pour la réussite de ces
examens
on est dans un lieu qui s'adresse bien
sûr en premier lieu à des étudiants est
ce que d'aider les lycéens peuvent
trouver tout de même des ressources des
documents peut être utile dans leurs
révisions
on n'a pas de collections spécialisées
pour les lycéens
ils peuvent éventuellement trouver des
ressources par rapport surtout au bac
français ou à la philosophie puisqu'on à
lunel collection littérature et
philosophie
mais notre principal documentation est
vraiment pour les étudiants alors pour
les lycéens qui viennent ici n'ont pas
forcément les us et coutumes d'une baie
eu quand on vient dans cet environnement
il ya forcément des règles à respecter
que faut-il faire
ne faut-il pas faire quand on vient ici
dans une bibliothèque universitaire
alors un principe dans le règlement
intérieur on précise bien les
usage d'une bibliothèque bien sûr de pas
trop parler fort et de ne pas manger ni
boire
on voit bien et de travailler le plus en
silence possible dans cette bibliothèque
on a mis en place un zonage des espaces
pour des zones de travail en groupe des
zones de travail en silence et des zones
de travail en chuchotant parce qu'on se
rend compte que les usages de travail
évolue beaucoup et que maintenant tout
étudiant ou lycéen ne fait plus que de
travailler en silence ils travaillent en
groupe ils travaillent en mangeant il
travaille en regardant sa page facebook
et quelquefois même ils dorment dans la
bibliothèque donc il faut arriver à
concilier sous ses usages et donc bien
sûr au moins respecter a minima le
silence la nourriture et les boissons
mais c'est pas toujours évident toute
dernière chose question très pratique si
on veut venir va réviser d'ici là elle
avait eu accueillera les lycéens
jusqu'au tout début des épreuves
comment fait-on il faut s'inscrire est
le préalable à l'entrée on a quelqu'un
qui accueille chaque lycéen et sur
présentation de son livre est de
de scolarité ou sa carte de lycée il est
automatiquement inscrits et bien
accueillis à la bûche
merci chantal merde je rappelle que vous
êtes la responsable de la bibliothèque
universitaire de l'ue vs cul et on
souhaite bon courage aux lycéens qui
passent le bac
merci